hey I'm reviewers I'm here at BuzzFeed
and I am here to talk about my first
times first impression of my Batwoman
costume I mean that was just like it's
my life real like is this am I really
gonna wear this every day this is I mean
oh you believe it's a lot less
comfortable than what I got to wear on
orange is the new black you've gone from
like a smock to a very tight fitting bad
suit that I can't pain but it looks so
cool and it feels so amazing and it's I
mean that that whole part is like a
dream come true
you'll have to like I have a bad suit at
some time guys I don't know how you can
organize it but just do it this is a
deep question I thought they were gonna
be like you know first time you watch
the symptoms it's finished a sentence I
want to be the first person in Hollywood
to when I feel like this is probably
already happened but I want to have like
a Giant Bomb with just like a million
rescue dogs but I'm sure I feel like
people have done that so we're the first
person to do it that mentioned it on his
show fest first celebrity crush oh gosh
because I know somebody wouldn't know
it's like a less funny down I mean Mandy
Moore was a was a big one
Billie Piper was like legit legit crush
met her it was not cool and Angelina
Jolie but that's like it's like I'm just
isolate oppression yeah she's watching
they say oh man first of my bums an
audition
it was so bad because I wasn't bad I
mean I bought probe bummed all of my
first auditions like in slowly you get
better and get used to auditioning but
when you've already established somewhat
of a career and auditions do I make you
nervous and then you go for a job that
you really want and I mean it was a I
was terrible it was for Deadpool true it
was for the dominant like my whole body
was just like shaking I couldn't even
like I don't know what happened but I
like literally walked out of there and I
was like I quit never again I'm ever
seeing any of these people I'm never
like and then I had to hang out with
Ryan Reynolds and I was like I really
wonder if he's a good take I really hope
he didn't see that tape it was uh I
would rather like a sex tape get
released there's no one of me ever but I
would rather that than that audition get
released ever this was not these are not
fair questions
first person I bonded with on the
Battlement set you realize we have a
really big cost and singling out one
person is a really terrible thing to do
I would never do that
Rachel who was your first real friend in
Hollywood and do you still speak it and
do you speak like no we just stare at
each other it's Hollywood see ya
who's I run clean she's Australian but
she was the only person I knew when I
got to Hollywood and so I am yeah we
still speak not as much as we used to
but I love her I saw her a couple months
ago she's the best love you yeah she
still has my dog I hope so
yeah I know she still has my dog I
rescued a dog and then had to get back
to Australia so I let I let see a habit
baby said a dog said it and then and
then she didn't give it back and and the
thing is the dog was named SIA
so then she changed it to Celia which I
wasn't happy about you know being the
original mum and so then she changed it
to cereal which is a good compromise but
she also like had Hut's built for each
of these dogs and I to be fair I was
gone for three months and not two weeks
like I said it had a really good arm
there and it's it looks really happy and
I don't think it misses me at all first
Wow first bad experience uh probably the
first fan to get my face doctor down
there buddy
she showed me she just came right up it
was like yay I was like oh yeah Wow I
was known as a good actor then I was
pretty freaked out um mostly good it
didn't look like me that much okay it's
like it not a great tattoo but but she
won't know I'm talking about because so
many people have it now and and lots of
other ones are great and wonderful I
just feel like when I'm older and not
cool people I'm gonna get all these
bills for the laser tattoo removal and
so I like I feel like now I have to put
a fund like there's my tax fund and then
there's my dog fund and retirement fund
and then there's like for all the fans
they've got my face tattooed but later
are gonna want to remove fund
it's getting a little hefty first time I
was das truck probably meeting slash
from Guns and Roses that was like when
I'd already interviewed a ton of people
for MTV in Australia and I met him and I
just like Rob loosening tweeze music I
was obsessed he was my favorite he was
my mom's favorite and he only did two
interviews in Australia at the time and
one of them was with me I don't know why
and the first thing I said to him was I
think I'm I'm gonna throw up on your lap
I mean they had like eight minutes cuz
you only get a certain amount of time
with seven people and I spent half of it
basically worried I was gonna throw up
on him and then we had like a 30 minute
interview and it was it was amazing then
I went to be sure and then he met my mom
yeah mom thought he was so I think he
thought that she was kind of cute too
wasn't what I wanted the first time you
got ten down for a role you really
wanted that Deadpool was great great
film
would like to fit in it the roles that I
get turned down for like genuinely it's
because someone's better than me no it's
I I watch it and I literally think
either the project's trash and I'm like
thank God I didn't do this because the
script was great but somehow didn't
translate or I watch it and I'm like
they did I really see that person
playing that character like I've never
not gotten a role and then what should
have been like I should had that role
that should have been me first kiss
probably in primary school which I don't
think that means anything to anyone here
it's like the school before whatever you
guys call the next school yeah
elementary school and we were playing
like kids would play like husband and
wife and like I way split husband was
and I kissed my wife on the lips she
loved it it was great we were like very
young she didn't gives me back she's
just like that's a fine I was like huh
wasn't it
thanks so much that was fun I mean it
was interesting it was different as I
knew it was nice don't forget to check
out Backman on CW I don't know when
you're gonna get this or maybe it comes
out now maybe it's out it becomes out in
a minute it really depends on when this
video goes to ask but by watch it's
great I think
[Music]